oh
is
crowd
wow
uh
foreign
as expected it's another ring totem
that's the source of the signal
looks like the banished are trying to
transport it off-site they must have
plans for it possibly research
can't let that happen
we need to take this operation offline
agreed we need a weakness to exploit and
for that we need access to the outpost
systems
get me to that control console
on fire
flowers
he's here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
got something a high-capacity fuel silo
is currently refueling their transport
if we destroy it it'll take the
transport along with it and bring this
operation to a halt
i've enabled a system-wide security lift
find a way to raise that
the
silo
i want their vehicles
is
i am done with you
hello
artifacts scattered across this ring are
key to the destiny of the banished
they are a link to this world's past
is
[Applause]
the only barrier between the banished
and our future
is
[Applause]
the station's powering down and that
transport is toast
banished research efforts on these
artifacts just ground to a halt